Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner, it's time for our 60-second cancer update.
This time we're going to talk about cancer and circadian rhythm.
Several new studies have come out recently, I talked about it in our blog, so you want
to more data, go to that.
But our circadian rhythm is really our hormonal rhythm and how hormones are secreted in our
body.
They're affected by a lot of things.
And the study showed that the more interruptions, or circadian rhythm disruptions that we have
can lead to an increase incident of cancer.
And for those who have cancer, an increase of the cancer cell growth, that was really an
interesting piece of this last study.
People that have cancer, that have numerous circadian rhythm disruptors in their life, increases
the growth of cancer cells.
You can see on the slide and pause it, you can see the different things that affect circadian
rhythm.
But we want to get to some things that you can do about it.
Try to keep healthy sleep cycle is really a number one.
Try to go to bed at the same time each night, try to live it screen time before bed so you
can get to sleep, use natural sleep aids like melatonin if necessary, no matter if melatonin
could be a great cancer help, learn ways to deal with stress and time management.
Check also your drugs that you're taking for side effects because they can be a major disruptors
in circadian rhythm.
Schedule regular rest and nap times, avoid estrogens and other hormones in our environment.
They can be major disruptors too.
All right, great news.
Talk to you next time.